if you think of a typical soft engineer
at Microsoft they spend about half of a
day on development related activities
and the other half of a day is spent on
how activities like coordinating with
our people in meetings sending emails so
it's actually not that much time that we
can spend on writing code and fee time
face spend writing code on a good day
it's actually only 96 minutes and on a
bad day it's on average 66 minutes and
half an hour writing code actually can
make the difference between a bed and a
good work day you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
if you're in software development dr.
Tom Zimmerman a senior researcher at
Microsoft Research in Redmond wants you
to be more productive and he's here to
help how you might ask well while
productivity can be hard to measure his
research in the empirical software
engineering group is attempting to do
just that by using insights from actual
data rather than just gut feelings to
improve the software development process
on today's podcast
dr. Zimmerman talks about why we need to
rethink productivity in software
engineering explains why work
environments matter tells us how AI and
machine learning are impacting
traditional software workflows and
reveals the difference between a typical
day and a good day in the life of a
software developer and what it would
take to make a good day typical that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Tom Zimmerman welcome to the podcast
thank you you have a cool nickname Tom Z
kind of like a rod or JLo but for
research why do people call you that so
it goes back to when I started at
Microsoft so my manager
it was Tom ball and so because my short
name is was it Tom so basically to Tom's
and get to find ways to distinguish
between us well you're a senior
researcher at Microsoft Research in
Redmond working under the umbrella of
programming languages and software
engineering in broad strokes what is a
typical day look like for Toms II I'll
ask you about a good day later but
what's a typical day what gets you up in
the morning so basically the work I do
it's analyzing any type of data which is
related to software and so what gets me
up in the morning is to basically learn
new things about software development
because there is so many things you
don't know we don't have any data about
so really what my job is about is to
basically look at such data and create
interesting insights that we can use to
improve software development at
Microsoft
so drill in there a little bit where do
you gather this data and what does it
look like so some of the data I collect
by myself sort of a lot of the work I do
is interviews and surveys with software
developers the other look a lot at
existing software repositories so it
happens doing software development is
that reservoir of data is being
collected so a state about changes about
bucks people face about test executions
and was like telemetry about how this
office being used in the field right and
so what I do as part of my work is
rockettes a state and do some analysis
and can be many different things so
sometimes it's empirical studies to find
out what makes soft engineers productive
sometimes it's building recommendation
systems so one of my earliest projects
was to build a recommendation system
based on past two changes to recommend
like people who changed sis file order
should change sasame file it's mostly
internal so a lot of the data we
analyzes internal macros
so it sounds like you've got to be sort
of cross pollinating with developers and
engineers in Microsoft proper and you're
here in Microsoft Research working with
them how does that work so we meet with
them we just send emails or scheduled
meetings of developers and half of em
and in fact actually if that's like one
big piece of the work I do is really
figuring out what challenges people face
yeah and the best way to find out his
challenges is by talking to people and
then after talking to people it's
basically can use additional data to
basically find support for the
observations you made well let's start
the podcast kind of generally and set
the stage for some of the other things
we'll be covering by talking a bit about
XE or the International Conference on
software engineering since it's
happening in Montreal about the same
time this podcast drops I'd love for you
to tell us what this conference is about
and why it's important for people in
your field yeah so XE is the largest
software engineering conference so
everyone who is passionate about
improving software development goes to
XE and finds out what everyone else is
working on so you will find a lot of
professors who do research on software
engineering you will find a lot of
people from industry who want to find
out what we latest research is about and
how it can help them in what challenges
they face right now right you will find
a lot of students who basically want to
start their careers so it's really good
for recruiting in fact a lot of the
interns I had over the past few years
I found it XE well you're part of a
group called es e or empirical software
engineering tell us why this group
exists and what you hope to achieve
through it so one of the reasons this
group exists is because I still a lot of
decisions being made just based on gut
feeling so like statistics fit 40
percent of management decisions people
just make based on what we think is
right but we don't use any data to
inform the decisions or what you offer
more so here is a people Quechua see
some data but when the data doesn't
match the gut feeling vague question of
the data until they either invalidate
the data or a finding or
matches what we were expecting so that's
really what he wants to change so what
we want to have is a people have a more
data-driven culture when making
decisions because there's so much data
available about software development
yeah by doing some analysis on top of
the state that we can learn things about
so engineering and that can help people
to make better decisions we can also
build tools to make people more
productive and so if it's like another
mission of a yearsI group yeah and we're
gonna get way into productivity shortly
give me an example of a decision that
somebody would make on a gut feeling
that could have disastrous consequences
or maybe to work out just fine but you
don't know right yeah so like one very
simple example is like trust management
structures like how you compose your
team's who is put in a management role
and who is assigned which manager that
can have like big implications on for
productivity and satisfaction or soft
engineers so that's some of the
questions that you're asking some of the
questions we asked so one of my
colleagues notching a gap on so he
actually did one study very looked into
healthy organization in hierarchy
effects the software quality and so he
actually found fit like a misalignment
into organizational hierarchy if it's
one of the biggest predictor of bugs in
software Wow and so in our study we did
in this space was one of my colleagues
Chris Burt he was looking into what
makes effective soft engineering
managers because software management has
so much impact on for software build so
it's very important for us to understand
what are characteristics of effective
management techniques you know we're
gonna talk about the management impact
on productivity of workers it sounds
like that's not just a software
engineering workplace question but could
have broad implications yes absolutely
yeah and I think that's what's unique
about empirical software engineering is
that it's not just software engineering
it's not just programming languages it
covers much more than just physical
disciplines like a lot of a work we do
it's very related to human-computer
interaction CSE W star
work we do a lot of AI in our research
as well because we often be like tools
which run from past data to support
decision-making
[Music]
in a recent paper entitled today was a
good day the daily life of software
developers I can't wait till that movie
comes out you asked thousands of
professional developers what constitutes
a typical day at work and what
constitutes a good day in hopes that the
answers will help you understand how to
make a good day
a typical day yeah yeah so what did you
learn from the research behind this
paper yes we've done actually quite a
few things so some of your findings
confirmed what we already knew which is
also important in empirical research
because often you think you know
something but you don't have any
evidence and that's why you do empirical
studies to support what your assumptions
are so one of the findings we had was
and that's probably not surprising to
many people but software development
involves many other activities fan just
writing code
so actually if you think of a typical
software engineer at Microsoft
they spend about half of a day on
development related activities and the
other half of a day is spent on
activities like coordinating with our
people in meetings sending emails so
it's actually not that much time that we
can spend on writing code and free time
face spend writing code on a good day
it's actually only 96 minutes and on a
bad day it's on average 66 minutes and
half an hour writing code actually can
make the difference between a bed and a
good work day huh so everything you're
saying has broader contextual
application as far as I'm concerned I
mean I think the average worker in any
occupation has to do email has to do
meetings has to do you know all the
mundane things and then you know if
they're a writer or if they're you know
an artist or whatever it's how can I get
to my work so the next question is then
with what you found that did confirm
what you think how do you get back those
hours for those minutes that time
basically four very approaches in this
particular papers you want
to understand what makes good workdays
and what makes typical workdays and so
we build different conceptual models so
if a vague approach it is we had this
big survey with Joseph 5,000 responses
and in each of three responses people
could say why every day was good and why
fidei was typical and so we analyzed all
of his 5,000 responses and came up with
frameworks and one of your frameworks
was basically for good work day things
that meta is for people see if if I
created some value so at the end of the
day if I want to go home and say hey I
spend a certain amount of time coding I
spent some time helping others to do for
work or I spend some time finding a bug
so they want to be able to say that they
accomplished something so I noticed how
you're framing this is a typical day and
a good day
you're not calling a typical day a bad
day is there something below there's
days that could be really bad right yeah
I mean I'm typical work day doesn't have
to be bad right because it can be
untypical because you just said like ten
hours coding time sure and if it comes
down to looking into productivity it's
actually a very complicated construct
like the many factors which come into
play if it can change if you're
productive if you have a good work day
if you feel happy about what you
accomplished well let's dig in on this
idea of productivity especially as it
pertains to programmers and developers
because that's what matters here one of
your papers you have so many cool papers
Tom it's really impressive one of your
papers is titled the effective work
environments on productivity and
satisfaction of software engineers so
tell us about this research and the
paper that came from it and what were
the big takeaways on the study of work
environments in relation to work
productivity yeah so it comes down to
again many factors can influence
productivity if we pre FLE talked about
management and traffic management work
environment is like another factor which
can influence how productive soft
engineers feel so the core of this
project was to understand
and what software engineers expect from
for work environment so what are things
that they consider to be important about
your work environment and how can they
help us understand productivity and
satisfaction so what we did is we
started off with interviews like as we
do many typically in our studies we did
some analysis of interviews and we
followed up preferred survey among Safin
genius at Microsoft and so what we found
was basically if it was like a set of
different themes which are really
important for software engineers and
probably for everyone is working in
office environments so it's not
necessarily saying so fringing is so
much different but it's confirming also
what other people found about what makes
good work environments so we found for
personalization is very important for
people we also found that social norms
hand signals are important in work
environments like when you are working
an Open Office certain signals people
use to say hey hey don't disturb me I
have to focus now for example wearing
headphones is one of the signals people
often do phenols are like our room
composition looks like so who's in the
room setting a few IO in the same room
as your team members or you in a
separate room if you can work without
interruptions and can focus on four
outfits also very important and so what
we did is we collected these different
aspects and when we did a survey and
society us to basically prioritize which
are the most important factors when it
comes to productivity and then you
present these findings to people who are
in charge of making the environments one
way or the other
yeah I would imagine there's a spread
there because there are some people who
can work in completely noisy
environments no problem and other people
who say just get out of my face yeah so
absolutely like people have very
different opinions of feelings and work
differently in different environments so
then is one of the takeaways to say make
space for these different kinds of work
preferences yeah so that's one of her
takeaways and how do you say it's a
takeaway of entire productivity research
we've done is
that's not a single way to make everyone
more productive right right for so many
personal differences you really need to
understand how everything plays together
and when you can make recommendations
for this is for intuitive people right
it's very similar to like going on a
diet or when you go to the gym like your
exercise routine everyone has their own
techniques which work best for them
right so it's not a single one size fits
all all right well we talked a bit about
the movement toward incorporating data
science to help programmers achieve more
and you have a seriously delightful
presentation called software
productivity decoded I wish our
listeners could see it especially the
part about Alice and Adalind they'll
have to come to one of your talks I
guess anyway this is important and
speaks to your unique approach to
software engineering research so how
does data science impact productivity
and help software engineers achieve more
so I think first it helps us to really
understand more effectively how software
developers work so you can think of
applying data science work to software
engineering and so I've mentioned all
these different data sources that we can
leverage and we also talked about XE
there's actually a conference just
dedicated to V analysis of software data
at XE we talked about acronyms it's
actually called VMs our conference but
it's not for Microsoft Research it's for
mining software repositories that's
funny and so it's this conference does
is basically people look at all the data
that is available for software and
software development and they try to do
cool things of it so I would come up
with interesting findings that help us
understand so fringe anymore or come up
with tours fit allow people to be more
productive so some people use data
science techniques to improve code
review processes for example you can
assign code reviewers to your changes
and when your change hopefully gets
reviewed faster so that's one area where
data science can help us to discover
more about soft engineering it can also
help software engineers to understand
more about how they work from service
it's sort of like fit
our watch right which keeps track of
your steps your heart rate and at the
end of a day you can look at it and
reflect on how active you were you can
do similar things with data signs so you
can pair tours which are our developers
to look at the end of a day to see how
much time they spend on coding how much
time they spent on emails or meetings
and fanfic can use this to become more
productive and also to understand how
our own productivity relates to routine
productivity because you always have
this tension between your personal
productivity but also productivity as a
team yeah so sometimes what's best for
your own personal productivity is maybe
not best for your team alright so one
thing you find is that people don't want
to be interrupted so they can increase
focus time fit helps people to become
more productive but it couldn't also
próxima who really need to help right
now if it cannot interrupt you from
might be stuck and don't make any
progress right and so what data science
can help us to is to really understand
this tension between individual
productivity and team productivity and
find effective ways to balance it those
are fascinating questions and
fascinating research it seems like
there's a really beautiful mix of
qualitative and quantitative in your
work and it's also is over into the HCI
space I know that there's researchers
here Dan Macduff and Mary chair Winsky
who are monitoring and then saying how
can we improve our tools to make us
understand when I'm in the flow and
don't get me out of the flow or when I
could be interrupted yeah quite a bit
yeah so we work together on some things
and it's very related for what we do
yeah all right well let's circle back to
EXCI because you're presenting a really
interesting paper there this year called
software engineering for machine
learning a case study which I love tell
us about this paper in the research
behind it how have you found AI cuz
that'll be in there to be sort of a
forcing function for an evolution of
workflows in the software development
process yes so what's happening at the
moment is fit more and more teams are
using AI
infra software and so what we are trying
to do is to basically processes whole AI
workflow how you build machine learning
models you collect some data you change
the models you tuned for models you test
a motor and Faye are basically trying to
fit this workflow into vegetation air
soft engineering workflow and it is
possible but it's not a natural fit for
example one very simple difference
between traditional software development
and modern software development if AI is
in traditional software development like
software testing it's usually fairly
easy to tell if a test has failed or
passed so as some exceptions but usually
you know if something has worked or not
right if you type in in Excel like a
head up to numbers you can tell if it's
some is the same right and if it's not
you know you have found a bug and this
is a bit harder for a imodels because
testing is not as straightforward
because you don't know what is a good AI
model and sometimes hard to tell right
right because you cannot test them
online you have to test them offline
first and it also might change over time
if you use new training data the model
might look completely different so it's
really hard to tell when you're getting
worse results when you did before so
that's really one of a challenges people
have to figure out and that's what we've
been looking into in this paper
mm-hmm so we started off with interviews
and we did surveys and collected data
and the analysis of threats of open text
responses well tell us a little bit
about the case study what did you look
at and how did you get your subject area
case so a case study is basically
Microsoft to find people who use
something called snowball sampling where
we basically identified a few people
knowledgeable in this area and they
recommend you they may recommend it
friends and we kept doing this on TV
pretty much thought we heard everything
so it's called saturation when you don't
get treated anything new and that's when
we started working on a survey to really
understand the landscape of AI at
Microsoft if you interviewers allow us
to go deep
yeah because you can talk to people
one-on-one and it gets us more richer
inside and then we want to confirm what
we observed in interviews with a
large-scale survey yeah and it was
allows us to look at some other things
like we looked into how much time people
spend on different activities and fit
questions about challenges we face it
makes me laugh because I you know what
was your case Microsoft it is oh and
you're lucky you've got access to this
place you're a busy guy Tom in addition
to all the research and papers you're
doing you're one of the editors of a new
book called rethinking productivity in
software engineering I'm detecting a
theme here the description says that it
collects the wisdom of software
engineering thought leaders in a forum
digestible for any developer I'm gonna
resist my urge to make a comment about
that and just ask you to give us some
highlights on what these thought leaders
had to say so basically if a book is the
outcome of actual seminar fatah head
co-organized and so we organized a
seminar on rethinking productivity in
software engineering yeah and so if it's
were or fees for leaders met and at the
end of a seminar we decided we wanted to
a book to basically summarize what we
discussed at v-- seminar so one of it
takeaways and this is again not gonna
surprise everyone but it's really hard
to measure productivity and often when
people think about productivity they
have like one or two measurements in
mind but it's important to take away fed
you need to measure many different
things if you talk about productivity if
you just focus on one or two aspects
you're not going to get a complete
picture because productivity depends on
so many different aspects like
management work environments which tools
you use what processes you use our go-to
team is how much experience we have so
many factors
which can affect productivity basically
what we were doing is discussing these
factors and coming up with ideas how to
get at a more complete picture of
software productivity
do you ever factor in things like life
events or illnesses or the kinds of
unpredictable edge cases yeah so
actually when we did this work on a
typical soft engine workday some of
these came up so if you have to go to a
doctor and family emergencies yeah so
that comes into play but you can't
predict any of those mean you prevent
them you cannot predict or prevent but
you can basically deal with how you
react to his cases
so having contingencies and thinking
ahead for the unexpected yeah infinite
also comes down and that's also part of
the book is so we have one chapter on
happiness of software engineers so one
thing that has been found in research is
fit happy software engineers are more
productive and our productive software
engineers more happy I think okay well I
like to ask all my guests to share their
version of what could possibly go wrong
because pure research is way upstream of
unintended consequences so tell us in
the context of your work is there
anything that concerns you or keeps you
up at night and if so what are you doing
about it yeah so what's happening right
now I think is like software is getting
more and more important right so you
cannot do much without software and if
you're working really hard to make
people more productive more happy more
satisfied when for your software but I
think what's also really important is to
think about the people who cannot use
software for various reasons or who are
not as good at using software so that's
one thing which concerns me give me an
example so I see it a little bit with my
parents oh yeah so there's certain
things are not as comfortable doing on a
computer which is totally natural for me
and I'm also gonna get older and I'm
gonna have the same challenges and I
sometimes see it already like for
certain things I'm like oh
it's getting a little bit too
complicated so if that's one thing which
worries me like how we can really potato
to everyone with software yeah is there
anything you can do about that because
that's an interesting conundrum that's
not new and it's gonna get worse I think
in a cloud era ai world yeah so I think
it's a tricky question and it might get
worse for a little bit but over time I
think it's probably also gonna get
better because right now you need to
interact with a computer if you want to
do something on a desktop computing to
use Mouse in keyboard it's much more
complicated but again with my parents
like once I gave him the touch devices
it was much easier for them to interact
with it right and if you think of what's
coming next if you do more voice control
it's probably also going to get easier
for people to interact so designing much
more natural interface yes will probably
assuage some of the problems that people
have encountered with an engineered
environment for what we use now yeah so
I like to know that personal stories and
career paths of the people I interview
they're often really interesting and
inspiring and sometimes they're actually
entertaining so regardless of your genre
tell us how you landed here at Microsoft
Research in Redmond all the way from
Germany with a stop I understand in
Calgary Alberta Kansas yeah tell us your
story
I took my PhD and saprykin incident in
Germany and so during my PhD I ended up
doing an internship at Microsoft
Research actually working on empirical
studies and it was actually very
eye-opening for me at that moment
because until then I only looked in to
open source projects and so when I came
here I learned really like what's
important for Microsoft for company for
large-scale software development what
year was that it was 2006 and I really
enjoyed my time here so when I finished
my PhD and I ended up going to
University of Calgary as assistant
professor for one year and then the
opportunity opened up at Microsoft for
me to become a researcher here and I
jumped on it right because most of my
research was very data-driven I
had a good time here during my
internship and I thought what better
place to be for data a Microsoft and
since then I've been here and I've done
data analysis of many different things
electron two games telemetry like how we
can increase player engagement on Xbox
and lots of software data about software
teams of productivity and so it's been
really interesting well it seems like
the research that you do has broad
application in any division around the
company do they let you out of 99 out of
99 or not so in fairness about being in
research because we can get to work with
many different product groups or many
different challenges and fail usually oh
very interesting
that's great because that's where
research becomes practical and helpful
in immediate situations yeah and the
other thing which was really great about
coming to Microsoft is so initially my
motivation was to come because of a data
but what I learned once I came here is
yours or get for people who you can talk
to about for data which is a very big
difference compared to more open-source
setting come for the data stay for the
people yep that's what about for people
along those lines here's a new question
I've been asking what's one interesting
thing whether it's a trait about you a
characteristic a life event that people
might not know about you and how has it
influenced or impacted your career as a
researcher okay so I've always been
fascinated by numbers and so here's one
thing I think only my parents and my
sister know when I was like little like
eight or nine I actually did my own
stock index so and it was the old days
it was before internet I didn't have a
computer so basically every morning the
newspaper came in I took the newspaper
was looking at his stock listings
looking a few numbers computing my own
stock index writing it down in like a
notebook and
kept it for quite a long time and so it
kind of started my interest in doing
data analysis were you a good analyst
for eight for eight I would say yes I
mean it was not a very clever stock
index and it's I just found I just liked
adding up numbers doing the average and
keeping track of it and you follow the
stock market now I sent a photo of a
stock market do you analyze how they're
analyzing so I don't do analysis on fish
stock market I think that people who are
smarter see what I'm saying
yeah I like it as we close Tom I'd like
to give you the chance to say something
profound to our listeners if there's
anything you believe would be
researchers in programming languages and
software engineering ought to know now's
your chance to say it I have something
very short and concise
it's that software it's morphin bits and
bytes it's all about for people how can
you close with anything better than that
Tom Zimmerman Tom Z thanks for coming on
the podcast today thank you for having
me
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Tom Zimmermann
and the science of programmer
productivity visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]